these aren't Christmas lights this isn't
a mutant lobster and this fearsome
looking creature is not something you'd
ever find at the end of your fishing
hook these are some of the rarely seen
sea creatures found deep in the ocean in
a world of total darkness using ultra
sophisticated photographic and sampling
techniques scientists working for the
census of marine life have inventoried
an astonishing diversity of life beyond
the oceans photic zone the part of the
ocean that's too deep for light to seep
through the census of marine life is a
10-year long international research
program aimed at cataloguing the
diversity and distribution of marine
life over 2000 scientists from 82
countries are participated in the effort
five of the censuses 14 field projects
plumb the ocean depths beyond the photic
zone the results have been astonishing
thus far over 5,700 species have been
identified thriving in a world that has
never known light they're a diverse
assortment of creatures exotic cousins
to species that live closer to the ocean
surface such as crabs shrimp worms and
jellyfish they feed mostly on marine
snow fine particles of decaying plants
and animals that drift to the bottom of
the ocean
they're a hardy bunch these deep sea
dwellers these fish call horns Ruffy can
live to be 100 years old
this fella is known as the Wildcat
tubeworm because like the wildcatters of
old Texas it drills for oil when it hits
a gusher it dines on chemicals found in
the decomposing oil then there are the
Dumbo octopus given that name because
they flop a pair of large ear like fins
to swim like Dumbo the cartoon elephant
add up to five feet long they are among
the largest of deep-sea creatures but
not much is known about them the Dumbo's
are poorly known so we are trying to
figure out how many species there are
and how to tell them apart
for example this Dumbo may be a species
new to science
the sea cucumber is a distant cousin of
the starfish that uses 15 tentacles to
sweep the oceans to trite us into its
mouth at the end of its meal it changes
shape and flies off to find another
nutritious mud bath by the time the
census of marine life wraps up its
mission next fall the five deep-sea
projects will have embarked on more than
200 expeditions the results of the
census will be announced in London next
October
you